it's a hard thing to talk about it's
it's what it is is when you're growing
up during our time i always say this
like during our time
you don't talk about family in public
you just don't do it especially like you
got a filipino mom and you know the
traditions were different you know what
i mean and you keep that kind of stuff
to yourself but even more importantly
the reason i was bringing it up today is
you know that my soapbox is mental
health yeah and the biggest problem from
our generation our generation you're one
generation
i think you're much younger than i am
yeah yeah but we still say the same but
same generation like but the stigma it's
attached yeah it was bad and the truth
is there's a lot of people out there and
i i i would imagine that you're getting
this back from oh
that have either a family member they're
suffering and it doesn't have to be
schizophrenia but the fact that people
just kind of try to sweep that under the
carpet is the biggest
i think the biggest problem today in our
society yeah and we don't take care of
our mental health the way we take care
of our physical health yeah you know if
you had a brother who
was in a wheelchair yeah you would
probably have been more apt to talk
about him yeah before you talked about
somebody who had a million yep
that's a horrible thing to even say i
hate even admitting it so even talking
about this and it came out in the book
did you have a problem convincing your
mom that this is something you should
talk about no
i i i you know
this is my life so this is something i
need to deal with no no but she's from
one generation beyond maybe this is not
something you share she was okay and
comfortable with chef
you know to be honest howie i didn't
even ask but she knows now
the whole world knows right and and i'm
glad it's out there how did your brother
react
my brother's been calling me a lot he's
been facetiming me
so you have a good relationship oh i've
always had a good relationship no i mean
about you writing about it is it he
accepting of that yeah
you should be 100 there is nothing
embarrassing about illness
any kind of illness you know it's kind
of funny i always talk about the fact
that if you go um i have a bad back
everybody has a chiropractor and
everybody has a bad back if you say i
have
you know i just got diagnosed with
parkinson's or somebody in the family
did nobody has a problem with that yeah
but when you talk about these kind of
issues every there is somebody that has
a problem with hearing those issues uh
but yeah
the thing about my brother and like you
said about stigma but it's also like
the beautiful thing about comedy and
especially the reason why i talk about
my family so much it's
i didn't even realize how much therapy i
was giving myself
you know what i mean to be able to be on
stage and laugh about certain situations
that were obviously so traumatic in my
life like when my sisters left the house
i always say that on stage i go
i go you know me just telling that joke
to everybody about my sister's getting
you know basically
kicked out of the house at 17. like do
you think that was a funny situation
when i was a kid no i was crying it was
it was traumatic to see my two sisters
leave the house
but for me to get on stage and tell
everyone else my my story and and
laughing about it and then at the end of
the show having
women coming up to me going i left the
house this season then i knew i wasn't
alone and then not only that they were
laughing at it so like we're all kind of
like healing from that situation here's
the dichotomy about what we're living in
right now and i wonder if you ever worry
about it jackie always asks when
comedians are on and do you worry about
getting cancelled or you know because
the the thing about comedy and i've
always said this always comes from a
dark place if you're a little kid
laughing at a clown falling down you're
laughing at the misfortune of this
person you don't know falling and maybe
even getting hurt yeah if you're going
to tell a joke of two guys walking into
a bar it's not a joke unless something
awkward and horrible you tell happens to
that guy yeah so comedy always comes
anybody who's a comedian has had
you know dark any human being has had
darkness in their life yeah you mind the
funny out of that darkness yeah so there
is nothing
it used to be this way there is nothing
off limits there is no such thing as too
soon for me i needed to make fun and
find the funny in it to even survive it
yeah and if i'm not laughing then i'm
crying so
[Music]
you